right here on stage at PAX Prime is Bob
Roberts lead designer on the game from
monolith software is it one of the
software died say that totally wrong
productions Bob welcome to the stage
thank you for coming first before we get
kicked off here do we hear in Sector G
if you have any Lord of the Rings fans
here I would also be yelling but it
would get really loud because I have ass
microphone thing I'm a huge fan and
during e3 you know we got to see a lot
of the game different sort of aspects of
it and you guys are showing off letting
people play here at the show floor as
well yeah that's right and we had had
some of you guys in the studio just on
Thursday to play the same demo we're
jumping very late into the game so what
you'll see here is like pretty far into
the story pretty far into the sandbox
your powered up quite a bit okay you got
to the point now where you're not just
killing everybody but you can start to
choose whether you want to dominate a
guy make him you know your soldier to
fight for you or you want to just
harvest him for the loot all right so
let's take a look right at it see if
we're gonna dominate or harvest for loot
or both or all its getting killed right
there oh sorry somebody the cave rat so
he's going to drop a ruin that you could
pick up and upgrade your weapon with
we'll see that's one of the warchiefs
that was one of the big bosses that just
got taken down there this is actually
from the Thursday event that you guys
were playing out at our studio uh-huh
and it looks like that was that was the
war chief but he's got three bodyguards
and this guy right here is actually one
that they dominated the blue there
indicates that he's dominated so this is
their guy he just became the new war
chief and it looks like they're gonna
probably send him on a mission gonna
send him to start mixing things up cuz
your goal here and this this sort of
like a you know lineup of all these
different works is the hierarchy that
you've worked your way through to get to
the warchiefs exactly and all these guys
are dynamic their procedurally generated
so these are all the bosses in this area
but you're never going to have the same
bosses twice like if you play the game a
second time your friends game a hundred
times in they're all going to be
different so in this case they just they
branded one of those bodyguards so that
they had a man on the
that went after his war chief and took
him out so is their guy takes over and
now they're sending him off on a riot to
start some chaos for them all right so
they're set you've set one more chief in
action so it's metal things up with the
other and now sort of escape to a
glowing white tower that's right back in
the open world here you can fast travel
between these towers there this is part
of the the dual protagonist character
we've got you know inhabiting the same
body you've got talion the ranger of the
black gates who's killed right at the
beginning of the game but he's not
allowed to die he's brought back from
death over and over by keller brim boy
who's the Wraith inhabiting him who's
the actually the elf from the second age
that forged the rings of power with
Sauron so he's a pretty powerful dude
pretty powerful do and he's Groundhog
Day in you in like the worst way
possible exactly or verb or hopefully
the best way by the best way possible
for house I mean maybe for Italians
mental state it's not super great but
certainly for us it gives us an awesome
chance to romp around this lovely
looking more door which then that's one
of the more striking things that I think
for me you know coming into it right
away and I knew you guys were in a
different era than sort of what I we've
seen on cinema of course but more doors
very diverse geologically diverse place
yeah i mean the the point at which in
the lore that we're kind of tackling it
saurons actually been away from Mordor
for thousands of years so it's had that
time to kind of grow back and become a
beautiful wild frontier again yeah turns
out not having like the lord of all evil
hanging out in you is good for the
complexion exactly so now he's just
coming back just starting to
industrialize and rip everything apart
again we got a little window into the
fertile kind of the landscape where you
could still feed his armies before he
strips it bare where you just tried to
do it we just tried to do a stealth
attack but it turned out that that
character was invulnerable to stealth
that's right that's something you can
sort of recon ahead of time or is not
just like gonna be a random roll on that
enemy and whoops now you gotta get get
loud if you if you put the time in to
strategize every every boss has a
weakness has some kind of way you can
exploit to take him out so you can grab
the other works in the in the world and
dominate them to peer into their minds
to get the intel on guys and then study
there
strengths and weaknesses so that's
something that keeps the game fresh to
the fact that these guys are all
procedural means they all get different
strengths and weaknesses every time you
play and you have different boss fights
and and so what you end up here like
this is the the mechanism right you go
into their mind like that and then you
can find out about some of the other
captains in war cheese so let's say
you're really excellent stealth player
there's going to be some of these guys
that are vulnerable to that end I am Bob
know that definitely not but you'll
always bump into somebody along the way
he's going to challenge that who's going
to be invulnerable to it and the same
was true about combat and ranged and
using the beasts that's another big part
of the sandbox is making just chaos with
the wildlife and that's you were talking
before the demo started about the
different about the terms open world and
sandbox and the latter kind of implies
that really getting your hands in there
and messing around and like sort of
being able to influence things in ways
to create unexpected situations actly
yeah we use both terms for this game a
lot because open world clearly implies
the like freedom of movement and
navigation explore where you want and
all that and that's definitely the case
here but we also like the term sandbox a
lot because it's just this this you know
toy set it's got all these little little
bits and parts that you start to feed
into the systems they start to play off
of each other and you can create all
kinds of crazy unexpected emergent
moments that's what's going to be the
most fun for us once we launch is it's
the same thing that made it fun to work
on for years you get crazy stories that
you never thought possible that just
keep coming up to surprise you I can't
wait to watch people's like stream
videos and screenshots see all the all
the shenanigans didn't sue well speaking
of story what we're taking a look at now
is a sort of a section from the story
and part of it that involves a familiar
face yeah so so this mission here is the
first story mission we've been showing
give you a little glimpse into what that
part of the the game is like actually
the the narrative of the game is
nonlinear as well it was written by the
lead designer writer on red dead
redemption Christian canna Meza I said I
love that game that was a huge win for
us to get him on board and work with him
on the structure and style so it's also
nonlinear like red dead but he has a lot
of fun fun characters to work with and
Gollum is a great one it's actually very
similar to
from red dead but uh he's you know at
this point in the Lord golems just had
the ring stolen from him from the filthy
Trixie Bilbo and he's off into Mordor in
search of it this is where he ends up in
the lore at this time that's where we
get to cross paths with him and of
course you're inhabited by the maker of
the rings of power so you have this deep
connection to the you know one of the
ring bearers Gollum oh yeah so he's kind
of leading you around the environments
he's trying to find these artifacts
these heirlooms of Pellegrin boar that
when you find them they sort of jog his
memory and help him remember who he was
and helped him regain his power so that
that's the mission we're showing here is
you get following golems tracks going in
and out of the physical world and
wraiths world to keep track at him and
then work your way in to try and find
what these artifacts and learn about gay
lover boy ok and then so so coming out
of this by the way that that work but I
mean won't you is that like a at seguro
he's a massive kind of super predator in
Mordor it's like twice the size of a
troll routes growl growl now but with a
girl so you know that's here actually
this is a good example of the ecosystem
in action you got the bait there it's
going to attract some Cara Gore's who
are like big lion big cat type predators
uh-huh but of course that gets his
attention to so he's going to come
rushing in and start a fight with them
which gives you the chance to sneak into
his cage just jet on by cuz no one wants
to run into a growl especially on a
grouch home term but you can see the
cave here like it is another part of the
sandboxes you've got the mountains have
these cavern systems and caves that you
can explore find collectibles find crazy
beasts in here aha so we're going to
sneak through here and and eventually
probably see him use Wraith world again
to track golem and also maybe find some
artifacts pick up some stories from the
thousands of years of layered history
that have built up in Mordor it's in
there yeah are these like growlings so
these little guys around rude yeah these
guys if they get if they escaped if you
don't get them before they get back into
their pits they'll come back out with a
crazy swarm and just overwhelm you so
crazy swarm coming out of the walls in a
cave sounds like my nightmare ah but you
know definitely a neat sort of threat
because I
there are a lot of diverse threats to
you I mean from the wildlife to the sort
of towering crowds although all the
diverse orcs and all that it's really
there's really a lot of nefarious forces
to deal with that's right and on top of
the sort of diversity in the wildlife
and and the basic works the fact that
the Nemesis system is like building all
these different kind of specific
strengths and weaknesses means those
orcs are pretty infinitely varied as
well that you got such a broad array of
sort of strengths and weaknesses to deal
with to strategize around so this this
is sort of going between the Wraith
world and the not very actual world not
ready for a physical world is a good
world there we go I that allows you to
do a little investigation along this
story line now is this are these do
these branches I mean this sort of cave
here is this a part that you'll only
sort of have access to when you're
taking on the story or may be able to
come back around so it's all open ended
and we want you to really have the
freedom to explore and do this stuff
whenever you want and the story missions
take place inside the open world but of
course there's a lot of other things
going on in that in that space beyond
just that kind of the character the
narrative so you know you'll always be
able to grab those collectibles to deal
with the things that would be there
otherwise and maybe if you spot
something you just didn't have time to
get because you were busy on the story
mission you can try and remember come
back and pick it up later all right well
certainly lots to do in the open-world
sandbox of Mordor in shadow of Mordor
Bob we've seen some good chunks of this
game and there there's whetting my
appetite for more when when you guys
could release in the game what's the
release date and I'm more platforms it's
coming out on sep tember 30th on ps4
xbox one pc 360 ps3 fantastic I can't
wait that's like a month away yeah are
you excited to launch this thing we are
all very pumped yeah awesome Bob well
thank you so much for coming on
you